e2 beaufreton délégué général de
l'association contribuables associés
bonsoir de vos photos merci d'être avec
nous c'est une pratique ancienne on
vient de le voir et pourtant on en parle
peu comment expliquer ce manque de
transparence selon vous il s'agit quand
même d'argent public
bonsoir tout d'abord alors effectivement
lorsqu'il s'agit de subventions il ya la
plus grande opacité en france d'ailleurs
ça ne concerne pas que les aides à la
presse on le retrouve dans les
associations les syndicats qui sont eux
aussi ultra subventionnés et sont des
pratiques qui existent depuis des années
et qui je pense au départ partait d'une
bonne intention qui est elle a pris la
pluralité des des voix qui pouvait
s'élever en france et qui petit à petit
sont devenus ces aides de plus en plus
importante
à tel point qu'aujourd'hui ça atteint
des dizaines de millions et on se rend
bien compte que personne ne sait
finalement comment ces aides sont
attribuées et encore moins le
contribuable parce que lorsque vous êtes
contribuables finalement vous payez pour
des médias et vous n'avez pas fait tel
ou tel choix et on se retrouve nous dans
une situation de prise d'otage et c'est
extrêmement opaque est très désagréable
et je suis bien d'accord avec vous c'est
ce que l'on demande c'est contré
l'associé depuis des années c'est à la
fois une publication officielle des
aides mais également des moyens
d'obtention parce que il ya aucune
grille de lecture et on comprend pas
pourquoi effectivement par exemple le
parisien à quasiment 16 millions d'euros
et puis d'autres titres n'ont que
quelques millions alors à ce moment là
pour nous expliquer pourquoi les puits
qui décide justement c'était ma question
prochaine dont on me dit qu'on ne sais
pas sur quels critères sont choisis ces
titres de presse parce que si on vous
suit bien le parisien appartient à lvmh
qui voit là n'est pas démunis de moyens
alors que peut-être que certaines
certains organes de presse peut-être
moins subventionnés en tout cas moins
riches
n'obtiennent pas sa subvention ça veut
dire ça alors ce que j'imagine quand
même c'est que il doit y avoir une sorte
de clé de répartition qui doit être
proportionnelle finalement au nombre de
lecteurs mais encore faudrait-il le
vérifier enfin en tous les cas
officiellement sam n'est pas fiché ça
n'est pas expliquée mais je pense que
c'est ça doit être ça ce qui revient à
une forme de représentativité mais le
danger de cette pratique si c'est bien
celle ci qui retenu pour attribuer de
l'argent public et je rappelle quand
même que chaque euro versé par l'état
est un euro payé par le contribuable et
donc les contribuables ont un droit de
regard mais au-delà de ça si c'était la
clé de répartition ça veut dire que
finalement plus un média à un nombre
important de lecteurs ou d'auditeurs au
spectateur parce que ça vaut aussi pour
d'autres médias un petit peu la
télévision etc
et bien finalement creuse l'écart entre
les grands médias nationaux et les
petits médias locaux entre guillemets
même s'il n'y a pas de petits médias et
on peut pas s'empêcher de penser que
derrière ces grands médias et bien
évidemment il ya toujours la main
nourricière et que lorsque vous recevez
des subventions forcément vous êtes
tentés d'être plus indulgent avec ceux
qui vous verse les subventions en tous
les cas on peut le penser
et d'ailleurs nous chez contribué
associés nous sommes une association loi
1901 ne percevons aucune subvention
d'argent public c'est interdit par nos
statuts très volontairement
déontologiquement pour justement avoir
une totale liberté de ton et pour qu'à
aucun moment ni l'état ni des élus
puissent se servir au travers de la
subvention d'un moyen de faire pression
pour nous de faire passer des messages
et je peux pas m'empêcher en tant que
praticien entre guillemets de me dire
que dans certains médias et vient
effectivement il peut y avoir de
l'indulgence quand vous percevez des
millions d'euros vous dites les
contribuables juste street ont eu droit
de regard puisque ce sont eux qui payent
est-ce que vous avez déjà tenté de
demander des comptes au ministère
de la culture sont ces subventions et si
oui que vous attend répondu c'est
l'omerta complète c'est-à-dire que vous
êtes noyé dans dans des dédales
administratifs ou vous n'arrivez jamais
à voir le bon interlocuteur
et comme vous le savez dans
l'administration française personne
n'est responsable
alors on a des effectifs pléthoriques
dans l'administration mais personne
n'est responsable tenter si bien que
vous n'arrivez jamais avoir de réponse
d'ailleurs c'est le grand drame
aujourd'hui des dépenses publiques en
france c'est que l'information est très
peu diffusé aux citoyens parce que je
pense qu'il aurait beaucoup de gens dans
la rue si c'était le cas et nous chez
contribuerait associés alors que
pourtant représente 350 mille membres
on a le plus grand mal effectivement
avoir des données publiques de ce type
je l'observais également dans d'autres
domaines en ce moment nous nous créons
un argus des départements et des régions
pour vérifier le niveau de dépenses des
départements et des régions
eh bien on a la plus grande difficulté à
obtenir la comptabilité des départements
et des régions de france
alors qu'on est en période pré
électorale puisque les élections sur le
mois prochain
et là encore on est obligé de servir de
saisir le service administratif de la
cada une sorte de police des polices qui
vient théoriquement imposées aux
collectivités autres de fournir des
comptes
eh bien on arrive malgré la cada
toujours pas obtenir ce chiffre
c'est dire c'est dire en france à quel
point la dépense publique c'est l'omerta
la plus complète et quand on a 60 2 % de
dépenses publiques du pib comme c'est le
cas en ce moment
et bien si on veut coller les français
qui payent des impôts continuent à payer
des impôts
eh bien l'état ferait bien d'être
transparent et de nous expliquer comment
et dépenser notre argent
merci l'association contribuables
associés mercière